Now, there's actually 2 different flavors of scan.
The one I just presented is exclusive scan.
The output at each location is a function of all the elements that came before,
not including the current element.
So let's see what the output would be if we do a sum scan on this 8-element input array.
So this is straightforward to compute, and let's just keep in mind
the output here is the sum of all elements that come before it but not including it.
Inclusive scan is defined slightly differently.
Whereas exclusive scan summed up all the elements that came before
and didn't include the current element,
inclusive scan instead sums up all the elements before and including the current element.
So let's see what the answer is here.
And so in inclusive scan, this element is the sum of all the elements up to
and including the current element.
Now, we're not really covering applications of the scan primitives in this lecture.
We'll do these in the next lecture.
So it's not immediately obvious why you might need both flavors.
But what you'll find is that some algorithms are best expressed using an inclusive scan.
Others prefer using an exclusive scan.
It's likely that if you use a library that contains scan primitives, you'll have access to both flavors.
Fortunately, it's fairly straightforward to convert between them if you need to.